thank you good afternoon everybody there
was been a great day the first day in
office and this habit you know this
opportunity to meet with the minister in
their Jha council for the first time and
we have very good discussions and I
think there is really a momentum in the
room where member states are ready to
find new ways forward to find ways
forward to unblock the block situation
of migration and also to cooperate even
more on the area of security and I will
just give you some examples what I think
is necessary when it comes to migration
I'm gonna meet with all of the Member
States bilaterally and Margaret ashiness
will accompany me to some of them and I
think it's important that we have in a
smaller format the possibility to really
talk through this complex area and what
I do think that we need to reinforce is
facts and figures there's a little bit
too much highly tensioned political
debate I think we need to cool it down
to be pragmatic and to try to find
cooperation or solutions because I think
this for true is the European Way are
working together if we are a good union
based on values based on solidarity and
on cooperation and it's time that we
show that also in the area of migration
we need to manage migration in an
orderly way and we can do it if we can
regain trust between member states and
also I hope that we can help to foster
that and we also need of course to go
from irregular migration and more legal
pathways to Europe and that's why also
the cooperation with third countries is
so important both for readmission but
also for legal pathways as affine
partnerships together with third
countries and of course that Turkey is
one of the most important countries for
European Union in this aspect so that's
why we prioritized to go the very first
week in office to Turkey so words also
on security I think a lot have been has
been
done and now as we have to focus to
implement the interoperability but also
to take some further steps to strengthen
their cooperation in the area of
security I think that security is about
cohesion in society when we are when we
have attacks or threats it's not only
the victims of a terrorist attack or the
victims of organized crime that are
suffering
it's like a poison in society and I
think that if citizens do not feel that
they are protected by their society and
security in one member-states depends on
the security in other member states
that's why we have or building their
security union and I think this is about
cohesion feeling that I am also
protected that what we have to fight
child sexual abuse fight trafficking
helping protect people to find their
cooperation and a cohesion in society if
we fail on that then will we see a
divisive society and that will also be a
risk towards radicalization criminal
activities drug abuse and so on so this
is about the cohesion in society and
this will be the approach for the
upcoming proposals that will make also
in the area of security the coming
mandate thank you